moment in chess friendship history
Magnus Carlson faced off against his
friend Eric Hanson the chess bra in the
bullet Chess Championship playing in the
same house the pair were traveling
together in Barcelona and happened to be
paired against one another in the first
round laughs and banter were shared as
they were served identical colorful
drinks early in the match Magnus
blundered a mate in one oh he's
plundered a mating one but after that he
sharpened right up until the black queen
goes to D2 like it is now because you
can't
after a final score of 16 and a half to
one and a half the two sat down together
for an interview I was hoping to to get
a clean sweep this was